fugas investigaciones cruzadas y
acusaciones veladas de Sabotaje el
gasoducto nostrim 1 que transportaba gas
ruso a Alemania pero que dejó de
funcionar como mecanismo de presión del
kremlin contra las sanciones y el
nordstrim 2 que nunca entró en
funcionamiento comercial por decisión de
Berlín presentaron fugas el lunes ambos
contienen todavía combustible a presión
entre tanto Rusia y la Unión Europea
iniciaron investigaciones para
determinar las causas y no descartaron
ni desde Moscú ni desde Bruselas que
hubiera premeditación no se puede
descartar ninguna opción en este momento
está claro que hay daños en el oleoducto
no podemos excluir ninguna versión de
los hechos sobre el motivo de esto antes
de los resultados de la investigación
oficial
obviamente cualquier acto de Sabotaje en
cualquier infraestructura es algo que
condenaríamos y en cuanto a las
reacciones futuras Tendremos que ver
dependiendo de los hechos exactos Una
vez que se determina
en paralelo Este martes se inauguró en
Polonia un nuevo gasoducto que
transportará gas noruego a través de
Dinamarca un paso en Pos de minimizar la
dependencia energética rusa
La era de la dominación rusa en el
ámbito del gas está llegando a su fin la
era que estuvo marcada por el chantaje
las amenazas y la extorsión hoy entramos
en una nueva era la de la soberanía
energética la libertad energética y la
seguridad reforzada la primera ministra
danesa presente en el acto tuvo que
decretar la emergencia energética tras
las fugas del nostre 1 y 2 e instó a
mantener la mano dura contra Moscú
Winnie
tenemos que luchar contra Putin con el
apoyo Ucrania con fuertes sanciones
contra Rusia y liberando los de los
combustibles fósiles rusos
muy preocupantes acontecimientos de ayer
con las fugas del North Stream 1 y 2
ponen de manifiesto la urgencia de
aumentar nuestra seguridad energética en
siete meses luego del inicio de la
guerra la crisis energética y las
tensiones por la posible escalada del
conflicto con la anexión de las
autoproclamadas republicas tras lo
referendos siguen marcando la Pauta del
conflicto y sus consecuencias dentro y
fuera de Ucrania